bircek 9 sınıf Önerim craf kar okuluna
YouTube'un en büyük craf kanalına
Hepiniz hoş geldiniz Paraf Z takımı
okula destek kımızın bugün geldik 4ün
gününe artık ikinci ünite harita kısmına
geçiyoruz ve çok şanslısınız gençler
neden biliyor musunuz bu harita kısmında
saçma sapan uzunluk alan hesaplamaları
Yerel saat hesaplamaları gibi saçma
sapan şeyler vardı ne oldu biliyor
musunuz kaldırıldı dediler ki ya bunları
bu çocuklar niye hesaplıyor E zaten
Teknoloji gelişti bunların hesaplarını
yapan bir sürü sistemler var Bunları
kullanmayı öğrensinler dediler saçma
sapan hesaplamalar çıkarttılar ve
gerçekten günlük hayatta
kullanabileceğim bir coğrafya müfredatı
önüne koydular Bu yüzden şanslısın
günlük hayatı öğrenmeye devam ediyoruz
Bu videoda ne öğreneceğiz biliyor musun
ya karşına bir harita çıktı bu haritayı
nasıl okuyabilirim ya ne anlama geliyor
Ya arkadaş bu haritanın şurasında bir
şeyler var Bunlar ne anlama geliyor
Günlük hayatta nasıl kullanacaksan onu
öğrenmeye başlayacağız bu derste Aslında
günlük hayatı öğrenmeye devam ediyoruz
Ben emimi aldım hazırım Sen de beğen
tuşuna basıp Hazırlandı isan O zaman ne
diyoruz Yunus hocayla bir defa öğren bir
daha asla unutma gelin şu derse para
fatal geldik gün 4 harita okuma harita
türleri coğrafi koordinatlara bakacağız
gençler bakın ha 2ci pdf'e geçtik bu
pdf'i zedu one.com sitesinden
indirebilirsiniz bütün pdf'leri renkli
orada indirip ücretsiz bir şekilde
kullanabiliyorsun şöyle bir şey beni
üzdü açıkçası Bakın pdf'leri size yeni
bir müfredat oldu bütün Sistem değişti
ortalık allak bullak Ken bunca kamp
yapıyoruz Size Z takımı ındaki bütün bu
hocalar olarak pdf'i renkli veriyoruz
size anlatımı yapıyoruz sırf eksiklik
hissetmeyin diye bunca şey yaparken ilk
defa şunu gördüm video izleme beğeni
oranı % 10'un altında 1000 kişi izledi
isse 100 kişiden daha az kişi beğenmiş
videoyu bu bizim motivasyonumuzu
düşürüyor gençler Sizden ricam bakın bir
yola çıktık sizinle 9 sınıf 10 sınıf 11
12 sınıf bütün seneler boyunca beraber
ilerleyeceğiz değil mi Sonra tyt ayt'de
sınavda da size yardımcı olacağız bunca
her şeyi yaparken sınavlarınızda an her
şeyinize kadar yanınızda olurken Siz de
bizim yanımızda olun bizim yanımızda
olmak bir beğeni atmak bir abone olmak
bu kadar bu kadar kolay bir şeyi abone
ücretsiz zaten şurada abone ol diyorsun
bu kadar takip etmek yani bu kadar
ücretsiz bir şeyi bu kadar fedakarlığı
Lütfen bir beğeniyi eksik etmeyin Evet
geldik şimdi harita öğreneceğiz sizinle
zevkli bir ders olacak harita nasıl
okunur bakacağız ama bakmadan önce
harita ne demek Bunu bilmen lazım ya
Yani şöyle ya Tamam hocam Harita kodumuz
ama harita ne demek ya Yani bunun
kavramını böyle ezberlemem mi gerekiyor
aslında şu kavramı
ezberlemenin mi sana bir ihtimal bazı
böyle kavram hastası öğretmenler var
sorabilir ama bu kavramı ezberleme gerek
yok çünkü bu kavramın içinde ü tane
temel kelime var bu kelimeleri
bildiğinde iş çözülüyor Bak şimdi
kavramı sana okuyorum yeryüzünün
tamamının ya da bir bölümünün kuş bakışı
içinin yuvarlak içine aldığım kısımları
Sen de benimle beraber yuvarlak içine al
çünkü en önemlileri onlar kuş bakışı
görünümünün belirli bir ölçek dahilinde
küçültülerek
düzleme aktarılması sonucunda oluşan
çizimlere harita denir Bak şimdi en
önemli şeyleri çizdim sana sınavda 10
puanlık sorudur bu Yani büyük bir
ihtimalle sınava girdiğinde bu soru
senin karşına çıkacak diyecek ki sana
hemen alttaki madde bir çizimin harita
özelliği taşıması için gerekli olanları
yazınız sen de diyeceksin ki hemen kuş
ölç düz kuş ölç düz ne diyeceksin kuş
ölç düz git kuş ölç sonra düz git
kodlamam bu kuş kuş bir tane kuş
düşüneceksin haritanın üstünde bir kuş
düşün tamam mı kuşu gördün mü ölçüp düz
gidecek yani kuş bakışı bir çizimin
harita sayılması için üç tane şey lazım
bize bir kuş bakışı görünüm olacak 2
ölçek dahilinde küçültülecek üç Bu bir
düzleme aktarılacak bir kağıda değil Bak
kağıt demedim düzlem dedim masa da
olabilir duvar da olabilir Kağıt da
olabilir karton da olabilir karton
derken Hocam kartografya bakın
haritacılık bilimine ne diyor
kartografya sana bir ödev vermiştim
nasıl kodladım bunu bir tane ödev
vermiştim Harita çiz demiştim sana
Nereye çizmiştim bu haritayı kağıda
çizersek yırtılır hocam demiştik kartona
harita çiziyordu kartografya karton ha
kartona harita çizmiştik diyeceksin
kartografya harita bilm Şimdi geldik bir
çizimin harita sayılması için demek ki ü
tane şey var Bunları da göstereyim sana
bir kuş ölç düz kuş bakış ne demek Hocam
bu kuş bakış bak bir kuş tepeden
baktığını düşün gelelim orada göstereyim
bak şu an Türkiye haritasını aldım
karşıma şimdi bakın ben bu Türkiye
haritasına tepeden bakıyorum dikkat
ediyor musunuz Sanki böyle Şurayı
kapatayım Hah şöyle böyle tepeden
Bakıyorum Bir kuşun bakışı gibi
bakıyorum değil mi kuş bakışı bu demek
işte kuş yukarıda uçarken aşağıya böyle
kuş bakışı bakıyor tepeden bakımı yani
kuş bakışı dediğimiz şey bu Peki hocam
ne kadar yüksekten bakıyoruz buna bunu
bilebilir miyiz İşte bu derste şuradan
harita okumayı öğreniyoruz ya bu dersin
konusudur gençler b Bakın şu aşağı
kamerayı görüyor musunuz
1835 kilometreden Bakı bakıyormuş Demek
ki 1835 kmlik bir yüksekteki kamera
bakışı bu şöyle gelsek 14.000
kilometredeki bakış bu şöyle baksak
55.000 km Daha uzağa gidemiyoruz en
fazla 63.000 kilometreden
bakabiliyormuyuz
Şu an ne yapıyoruz kuş bakışı baktık
Tamam kuş bakışı baktık hocam Peki
buradaki Ölçek ne gençler bakın bir
haritayı
oluşturabilmek adar büyük bir yeri
ölçmemiz küçülttüğümde bu haritanın bir
köşesine yazmam lazım ki insanlar şunu
demeli ha bunu ölçmüş biçmiş 10.000 defa
küçültmüş 1 milyon defa küçültmüş bu
haritaya koymuş işte ölçek ölçek bak
ölçek adı üstünde bak kavrama bak ölçmek
biçmek küçültmek ne kadar küçülttüğümde
gösteriyor bize Tabii sana Bunu aklında
kalsın diye kabaca böyle anlattım ölçe
konusunu bir sonraki videoda ayrıntısına
kadar öğreneceğiz merak etme şu an
sadece şunu bilsen ölçek ha bu ölçmek
biçmek küçültmek için kullanılan kısım
hocam demen yeterli tamam ölçtük biçtik
kuş bakışı baktık Ee ölçtük piştik bunu
bir de düzleme aktardım mı İşte o zaman
senin karşın bir harita çıktı Anlaştık
mı sınavda 10 puanlık soru hemen şuraya
notunu al 10 puan hocan Sana buradan bir
soru çıkartır Demek ki harita kısmı
buydu şimdi Gelelim asıl şöyle biraz
daha Yaklaştır şöyle Tamam şimdi oldu
şimdi gelelim günlük hayatta karşına bir
harita çıktı Nasıl okuyacağım bunu bakın
bunu ders olarak düşünme şu anki kısmı
şu an günlük hayatta karşına bir harita
çıktığında onun içerisinde bazı
elemanlar var o elemanlara bakarak bazı
şeyler öğreniyorsun mesela ya bu
haritanın kuzeyi neresi Hım şu köşesinde
sağ alt köşesinde bir işaretler var ama
bunlar ne anlama geliyor Tamam Mesela bu
haritanın konusu ne gibi şeyleri bilmen
için haritanın unsurları haritayı
oluşturan elemanlar var bunları bilmen
lazım ezberleme Bunları sadece Bak
mesela bir haritada eline aldın bir
haritayı ya bir başlık olmaz mı değil mi
bir başlık olması lazım Çünkü o Başlığa
bakacağım o haritanın konusunu
öğreneceğim ha ne amaçla yapıldığına
bakacağım Mesela bu haritaya bakalım bu
da senin bir sınav sorun 10 puanlık
sınav sorusu ona göre dinle Burası tam
yani haritanın elemanlarını böyle bir
harita verir sana Tamam mı Boş olur
şuraları boş olur haritanın elemanlarını
yazınız der gel beraber yazalım Bak İç
Anadolu bölgesindeki fiziki harita bu ne
başlık değil mi bizim ilk öğreneceğimiz
şey başlık bize o haritanın konusunu
amacını gösteriyor Bir haritanın başlığı
olacak bu basit zaten ikincisi haritanın
bir ölçeği olacak Az önce demiştim ya
sana ölçüp biçip küçültmüş bu haritayı
bakın şöyle He Bakın şu kısmı görüyor
musunuz burada bir çizgi var bu bir
çizgi ölçek bazen de bu böyle kesir
ölçek şeklinde gösteriliyor bakın şöyle
bir sonraki dersin konusu bu öl İşte bu
kısmı da ölçek diyoruz Bu kısım bize bu
haritanın kaç defa küçültüldüğü
gösteriyor Tamam demek ki bir de ne
olacak hocam ölçek olacak ölçeği de
yazdık başka Hocam bir de bakın şurada
bir tane bir şey var böyle bir yıldız
gibi Aslında o bize yönleri gösterir yön
oku bu bak şunun ismi ne yön oku bize
yönleri gösterecek şimdi haritalarda
bazen yön oku olmaz gençler yani şu
olmayabiliyor haritalarda O zaman biz ne
diyoruz biliyor musunuz ha bu haritaya
baktım bunda yön oku yok ha H hocam o
zaman har ın bakın şöyle üst tarafını
gösteren kısmı Kuzey anlamına geliyor
Tamam mı Eğer yön oku yoksa diyorum ki
ben ha hocam yön oku yok bunda o zaman
böyle kuzeyi gösteriyor kuzeye bakan
tarafı diyoruz tamam mı Bu ayrıntıyı
unutma yön okunu da işaretledikten
[Müzik]
ve meridyenlere bölmüşler bu haritayı
İşte bunlar da bizim Coğrafi
koordinatlarımı bir haritada Bu coğrafi
koordinatların olması gerek olmalı Çünkü
bizim yerimizi bulmamızı sağlıyor bu Ben
diyorum ki 35 Doğu meridyeni ile 39
Kuzey paralelinin kesiştiği yerdeyim
diyorum tam bu ikisinin kesiştiği Yeri
bulup coğrafi koordinatım buluyorum Az
sonra coğrafi koordinatı göstereceğim
sana böyle nasıl bulduğumuzu da
işaretleyerek öğreteceğim sana çünkü
sınavda çıkacak 3üncü sorun da o olacak
tamam şimdi coğrafi koordinat olması
lazım demek Buna da biz bakın Ne diyoruz
paralel meridyenler yani coğrafi
koordinatlarım da var mı Tamam geldik
artık 5 kısma bunu en sona sakladım
çünkü en karıştırdığım bu Lejant Bu bize
haritada haritada haritanın işaretleri
Bunlar haritada bize yol gösteren yol
gösteren işaretler yol gösteriyor bize
nasıl yol gösteriyor hocam aslında bir
haritada Bana göre benim için en değerli
olan da bu niye biliyor musunuz Çünkü
ben bu haritaya bakıyorum ya böyle
renkler var bu haritada değil mi ya bu
renkler ne anlama geliyor ben bunu
bilmiyorum ki ya Bunu ezberlemem mi
gerekiyor benim Hayır işte bana birinin
yol göstermesi lazım o da buradaki
Lejant oluyor nasıl yol gösteriyor diyor
ki bana bak bak diyor genelde sağ alt
köşede bu yükseklik ve derinlik
basamakları Demek ki bu renkler
yükseklikle alakalı bir şey geldim diyor
ki bana bak diyor 500' ile 1000 metre
arasında olan yerler sarıdır diyor bak
sarı renge boyadım Tamam geliyorum
haritaya Ha demek ki Aa bakın şurada
Konya Ovası Konya Ovası sarı renkte
gösterilmiş demek ki He 500 ile 1000
metre arasında bu Konya Ovası bakın Neyi
anladığımı gördünüz mü bakıyorum Mesela
bu haritaya baktım ya inceliyorum şimdi
karşıma bir harita çıktı günlük
hayattayım böyle ya Ne bu kahverengiyle
işaretlenmiş buralar ya da sınıftasın
duvarda olur ya sınıfın hep duvarında
böyle haritalar ya bakıyorsun
Türkiye'nin doğu tarafları böyle
kahverengiyle işaretlenmiş ya Ne demek
bu acaba bakalım Lejant kısmını hemen
açıyorsun o zaman He hocam bu kahverengi
şöyle bakalım koyu kahverengi Ha yok
açık kahverengi o zaman şurası açık
kahverengi Hocam bu o zaman 1500 ile
2000 metre arasında olan yerleri
gösteriyormuş bana Hatta şurada bir
bakıyorum aladağların Tepesi koyu
kahverengi He Demek ki aladağların
Tepesi 2000 metrenin üstündeymiş
Anlaştık mı demek ki Lejant bana
haritada yol gösteren işaretler demiş
nasıl kodlayaz bunu şimdi coğrafyanın
kodları Bak bu kanalın ismi sana öyle
bir kavramı gösterip Bu da Lejant yol
gösteren deyip geçmem ne yaparım
kodlarım niye Çünkü ne diyoruz Yunus
hocayla bir defa öğren bir daha asla
unutma 4 sene sonra üniversite sınavına
gireceğin zaman da bu Lejant kavram
aklına gelsin nasıl gelecek le jant jant
var orada bak jant var orada e jant
araba arabanın jantı arabada yolda
gidiyor yol gösteren ha hocam
Lejant yol yolda gidiyor jant hocam
haritada yol gösteren işaretler Bunlar
hocam haritanın lejantı Sadece böyle
Sadece şurada gördüğümüz gibi mi olur
Hayır her haritanın farklı lejantları
olabilir Mesela bir harita açarsınız
şöyle bir lejantı olur tamam mı Şöyle
bir siyah nokta olur şey siyah çizgi
olur ya da şöyle bir üçgen olur Ne
bileyim şöyle bir alan olur değil mi siz
göremiyorsunuz ha Benim ekranım dondu
dur açıyorum bazen böyle donabilir
gençler şöyle bak der ki karşısına bir
ok çizer der ki bu Demir yoludur demir
yolu İşte bu petrol kuyusudur petrol
petrol direğidir falan der şu göldür der
tamam böyle bir işaretler koyar sen de
haritada böyle siyah bir çizgi
gördüğünde ha gelir buraya A bu Demir
yoluydu dersin Böylece haritada Her şey
sana yol göstermiş olur anlaştık mı
buraya kadar çerçeve çerçeveyi getirdim
bakın çerçeve burada çerçeveye alıyor
Bakın Gördünüz mü çerçeveye alınacak
sınırları gösteriyor çerçeveye aldım
haritayı havada durmuyor harita Tamam
çerçeve yön oku coğrafi koordinatlar
haritada yol gösteren Lejant ölçek
haritanın başlığı 10 puan toplam 20
puanlık bir bilgi öğrendin Bir de
ayrıntı sormak isteyen bir hocan olursa
diye şöyle sana 1 2 3 puanlık Püf nokta
vereceğim Kroki kroky nedir krokiler
gençler Bir yerin kaba taslak çizimini
ifade eder ne demek hocam kabat taslak
yani Kroki ne demek Hocam şimdi ben
Diyarbakır'a geleceğim değil mi şimdi
Önümüzdeki gezim biliyorsunuzdur
anlatmıştım size önceki derslerde her ay
bir şehri geziyorum Ben 15 gün bir
şehirde kalıyorum 15 gün gelip evde
video çekiyorum oradaki vlogları
atıyorum editliyorum Hem de böyle ders
çekiyorum size 15 gün şimdi
Diyarbakır'da olacağım şimdi
Diyarbakır'ın merkezindeyim diyelim ve
ben bilmiyorum orayı bir öğrencim de
karşıma açık öğrencime dedim ki ya
öğrenci bana şu Diyarbakır'ın en güzel
Ciğercisi Yerini tarif etsene ciğer
yemeye gideceğim Diyarbakır'da ciğer
yiyeceğim kahvaltıda ya bana bunun
yerini bir çizsene diyeceğim ya öğrenci
ne yapar alır eline değil mi böyle alır
bir kağıt şöyle bak kaba taslak olarak
çizer değil mi Bir ölç ölçerek biçerek
küçülterek mi çizdi bu öğrenci yok ne
yapar alır böyle bir kaba taslak olarak
H şurada Hocam şu şey var Okul var
okuldan iki sokak ileri gideceksiniz
sonra sağa dönersiniz diye böyle çizdi
ama nasıl çizdi bir kuş bakışı olarak
çizdi mi Evet Bakın şu öğrencimin Benim
az önce çizdiği şey olarak varsayalım
Tamam mı Şimdi bunu bir kuş bakışı var
mı tepeden bakma var mı var kuş bakışı
var Tamam bunu bir düzleme aktardı mı
Evet düzleme de aktardı Ama bunda bir
ölçek ölçek yok şöyle şöyle bak şöyle
ölçek yok bunda Niye Çünkü kaba taslak
çizil krokiler gençler kroki kaba taslak
çizilir ölçekleri yoktur profesyonel
değildirler O yüzden ölçeği yoksa harita
sayılır mı krokiler harita değildir
Tamam planlar Hani bu mühendislerin
vesaire çizdikleri planlar oluyor ya
onları ölçerek biçerek çiziyorlar O
yüzden onlar harita sayılır ama krokiler
yaz oraya Not not düş oraya şöyle şuraya
not düş bak ölçekleri olmadığı için
harita sayılmazlar önemli bir püf
noktaydı karşına çıkacaktır burayı
geçtik harita kısmının O kısmını geçtik
geldik harita türlerine buraya kadar
Tamam mıyız hangi sınavda nasıl bir
şeyin çıkacağını sana söyledim Sen de
notlarını aldın 100 almazsan sınavda
kafanı kırarım sen senin bak şimdi
geldik harita türlerine Gençler biz
haritaları kullanım amacına göre
kullanım amacına göre ikiye ayırıyoruz
aslında çok basit bir ayrım neden bir
genel haritalar adı üstünde Yani
herkesin kullanabildiği Bak genel Senin
baban da onu kullanır görür babanın da
karşısına çıkan haritalar genel herkesin
karşısına çıkan harita demek bir de ne
var tematik haritalar var tematik
belirli bir tema için çizilmiş Bunlar
belirli bir tema belirli bir konu için
çizilmiş y yani Bak ipucu kodlama burada
yani biri bana sordu ki böyle
sorulabilir sana kullanım amacına göre
haritaları ikiye ayırarak Örnek veriniz
dedi Der Hemen buraya bir 10 puanlık
sınav sorusu diyelim Sen de hemen He bir
hocam bir babamın kullandığı haritalar
vardı diyeceksin genel herkesin
kullandığı Harita Genel harita
diyeceksin Bir de hocam babamın pek
işine yaramayan ama benim gibi özel
kişilerin kullandığı özel kişisin Tabii
ki özel kişilerin kullandığı bir tema
için oluşturulmuş bir konu için
oluşturulmuş tematik haritalar var ne
demek hocam Yani bunlar bakın senin
Şimdi baban Şimdi baban bir Atlas
kullanır mı kullanır değil mi alır bir
Atlas ihtiyacı olur Bir evin bir Atlas
ihtiyacı vardır baban bir atlasla
karşılaşabilir baban bir duvar haritası
kullanabilir bir fiziki harita siyasi
harita kullanabilir topografya
haritaları yer şekilleri haritaları
Bunlar şimdi bunları Bunlar genel
Herkesin bir şekilde ulaşacağı haritalar
Ama bakın tematik haritalar Bunlar daha
kişilere özel haritalardır kişilerin
özel olarak ulaşacağı haritalardır
mesela sen hiç babanın ya gideyim de bir
Jeomorfoloji haritası kullanayım bakayım
bu haritaya dediğini duyamazsın baban
Tabii ki bunları kullanan birisi değilse
Yani işi bu değilse gideyim de ben şu
bitki örtüsü haritasını yok Bunları özel
olarak bulman özel olarak kullanman
gerekiyor Bunlar tematik haritalar
Anlaştık mı burada şunu şuna dikkat
etmeni istiyorum Bakın tekrar söylüyorum
atlaslar duvar haritaları atlasa da
ulaşabilir baban çok rahatlıkla Bunlar
genel haritadır unutma ve dikkat et
Bunlarda bu çıkacak karşına ayrıntı
azdır ne demek hocam çünkü bunlar
gençler çok büyük alanları gösteriyorlar
ve içinde genel Ya bunlar her şey var
genel olduğu için çok fazla ayrıntı
gösteremezler ezberleme bunu mantıken
düşün çok fazla ayrıntı gösterebilirler
mi mesela gençler bizim şimdi şu dünya
haritaları kitabımız var sana ne dedim
bu dünya haritaları kitabı Senin yeni
nesil atlasın dedim bu yeni nesil Atlası
9 sınıfın başında öğrenirsen bir daha 4
sene boyunca haritalarda problem çıkar
yaşamazsın dedi Her coğrafya öğretmeni
derse geldiğinde ilk ne yapar herkes
Atlası alacak değil mi Herkes Atlas
alacak bazen Belki de size zorunlu Atlas
aldırmıştır amaama o zorunlu Atlas bir
işe yaramaz Neden Çünkü ayrıntıyı
göstermez o atlaslar ayrıntı azdır her
şey karmaşıktır iç içedir mesela o
atlaslar genel haritalardır Mesela bu
kitap tematik Neden Çünkü mesela sadece
çölleri gösteriyor görüyor musunuz
sadece çölleri gösteriyor belirli bir
tema için yapılmış bu sefer ne oluyor
Bakın bu tema tematik bir harita tematik
harita ayrıntıyı daha fazla gösteriyor
görüyor musunuz sadece çölleri göstermek
için açalım sadece dağları göstermek
için görüyor musunuz şurada Ne oldu bu
bir tematik harita sadece dağlar var
sadece Çöller var tematik haritada
ayrıntı daha fazla oldu ama genel Atlas
alsaydınız Siz eğer o atlasta çölü
bulmaya çalışacaktım Dağı Ayrıca bulmaya
çalışacaktım ayrıntı atlaslarda azdır
yani Ama tematik haritalarda bu örnek
Benim kitabım örneğe Gelecek aklına
ayrıntı daha fazladır Peki hocam Bu
haritalar neler bunları bilmen lazım
Mesela fiziki har diyor bize ne demek
Hocam bu fiziki harita coğrafya ikiye
ayırmıştı beşeri coğrafya fiziki
coğrafya fiziki coğrafya niyi
inceliyordu dışarıdaki doğayı
inceliyordu değil mi bakın fizik harita
dağ ova plato vadiler dışarıdaki doğayı
gösteren haritalar fiziki coğrafyayı
gösteren haritalar bakın alın fiziki
haritalar böyle renk kademelerini
gösterir Size az önce görmüştük ya bir
haritada sarı şu basamakları
gösteriyordu kahverengi işte 2000 metre
üstünü gösteriyordu değil mi İşte fiziki
harita haralar bize dağları ovaları
platoları fiziki coğrafyayı gösteren
haritalar Bunlar nasıl genel harita Buna
herkes ulaşabilir mi Evet ulaşır geldik
bakın Siyasi ve İdari bölünmüş
haritalara bunlar da genel sürekli
karşımıza çıkan haritalar bir ilçenin
bakın Bir ilin ilçelerini göstermiş
bakın tek tek ilçelerini göstermiş ya da
bir Türkiye'yi karşınıza koyup oradaki
illeri gösteriyor siyasi harita idari
harita Tamam Demek ki bunlar da genel
harital mış tematik haritalara örneklere
bakalım bakın Türkiye'nin deprem
haritası belirli bir konu için belirli
bir konu için yapılış bunların ayrıntısı
fazla Evet şimdi Demek ki orada da bir
10 puanımız var yani şurada bir 10
puanımız var Sana şunu verecek kullanım
amacına göre haritaları yazınız diyecek
başa dönelim şimdi bu dersin başına bir
şeyin harita sayılması için düzlem
olacak kuş bakışı olacak ölçek olacak 10
puanı koyduğum ce Bir haritanın
elemanları vardı başlık olacaktı yön oku
olacaktı yön oku olmasa da olabiliyordu
Kuzey diyorduk o zaman Lejant vardı yol
gösteriyordu bize bir çerçeve olacaktı
coğrafi koordinatlar olacaktı başka bir
şey unuttum mu yön oku çerçeve harita Ha
bir de ölçek olacaktı Tamam 10 puanlık
2ci soru 10 puanlık 3 soruyu öğrendik
haritaları Ayırınız genel harita ha
genel herkesin ulaştığı haritalar
diyeceksin örnek olarak hocam herkes kim
Hangi haritaya ulaşır ha siyasi
haritalara ulaşır Türkiye siyasi
haritası dünya siyasi haritası mesela
Türkiye fiziki haritası Dünya fiziki
haritası örnekleri de böyle yazacaksın
tematik haritalar ha bir konu için
yazılıyordu Jeomorfoloji haritaları
bitki haritaları Toprak haritaları
bunları da örnek olarak verdik 2 10
puanlık soruyu da yaptık şöyle bir bilgi
var gençler şimdi bizim haritalarda bazı
şeylere ulaşabildiğimiz haritalar var
ulaşamadığımız haritalar mesela normal
bir haritaya baktığımızda Yani bütün
haritalara baktığımızda yönü bulabilir
miyiz bulabiliyoruz yön oku var çünkü
yani her haritadan yönü bulabiliyoruz
Yoksa da Kuzey gösteriyor demişti konum
belirlenir haritalarda niye coğrafi
koordinat var çünkü değil mi bütün
haritalara bakarak konumunu
belirleyebilirsin Tamam bütün haritalara
bakarak alan hesaplaması yapabiliyoruz
Biz oranın alanını hesaplayabiliyorum
Göstereceğim size sonraki videoda
haritalara bakarak bütün haritalara
bakarak yerel saatleri de bulabiliyoruz
Çünkü Her meridyen arasında 4 dakika var
yerel saatleri de bulabiliyoruz bütün
haritalara bakarak uzunluk da
hesaplayabiliyorum ama bir yerde
yükseltiyi bulacaksa eğimi bulacaksa
profil çıkartacaksın fiziki harita lazım
bize Hocam ben bunu ezberleyeceğim mi
Hayır bak şimdi sen Türkiye siyasi
haritası şehirleri gösteren harita
verdim sana Sen şimdi bir şehri gösteren
haritayı haritaya bakarak yükselti
bulabilir misin bulamazsın Senin
yükseltiyi bulabilmenin için senin şöyle
bir fiziki haritaya ihtiyacın var o
yüzden bir yükseltiyi bulman için bir
eğim Bak bunlar hep fiziki şeyler değil
mi eğim yükselti bunları bulabilmenin
senin bir fiziki haritaya bakman lazım
Türkiye'nin illerini gösteren bir
haritadan eğimi nasıl bulacağım ya
mantıken düşün ezberleme bunu Yani şöyle
açtım bir Türkiye'nin illerini
gösteriyor bana bu harita nasıl eğim
bulacağım ben burada Nasıl yükselti
bulayım bulamam Demek ki yükselti eğim
bunları bulabilmenin fiziki harita lazım
sana profil çıkartmanın fiziki harita
lazım Tamam hemen şöyle 10 puanlık sınav
sorusunu yazalım bir çizimin harita
özelliği taşıyabilmesi için bazı
özelliklere sahip olması lazım bu
özelliklerin neler olduğunu yazınız
hemen yazıyorum şöyle küçülte şunu kuş
bakışı ölçek dahilinde küçültülmesi
lazım Bir yerin kuş bakışı görünümü
olması lazım ölçek dahilinde
küçültülmesi lazım ve bir düzleme
aktarılması lazım dedik sınav puan
sorumuzu da ayarladık yukarıdakilerden
hangileri genel haritalarını genel
harita diyor babamın bile ulaşacağı
harita hemen ne yaptım
somutlastirmak doğası beşeri coğrafyası
genel haritalar bakın duvar haritaları
ile atlaslarda yer alan haritalar bu
türdendir Evet duvar haritası herkesin
ulaşabileceği Babamın ulaşabileceği bir
haritayı özel bir kullanım amacına uygun
olarak hazırlanmıştır Hayır babam buna
ulaşamaz bir toprak haritasına özel bir
haritaya ulaşamaz Klimatoloji
Jeomorfoloji bitki bakın Bunlar özel
harita değil mi özel bir konu için
çalışılmış hangisi ölçeklerinden genel
haritanın özelliklerinden değildir 3 ve
4 genel haritanın özelliklerinden
değildir Cevap D geçelim konumuzun diğer
kısmına geldik coğrafi koordinatlar
gençler bakın açalım buradan gösterelim
size şimdi geçmişte ne yapılmış şimdi
Bakın şimdi Google'ı açtım size değil mi
burada böyle çizgilerle karşılaşıyor
bazı çizgiler yatay çizilmiş bazı
çizgiler dikey çizilmiş görüyor musun Ya
arkadaş dünyada böyle çizgiler mi var
Yani şöyle dünyaya baktığımda Ben böyle
uzaya çıksam ve tepeden böyle baksam
dünyada böyle çizgi mi görürüm Hayır
böyle çizgiler yok Bunlar hayali
çizgiler Peki hocam niye böyle hayali
çizgiler koymuşlar Çünkü yerimizi tespit
etmemiz için bizim bir sabit değere
ihtiyacımız var o değeri de herkesin
bilmesi lazım demişler Ve dünyaya
herkesin o değerleri bildiği çizgiler
atmışlar bir başlangıç koymuşlar o
başlangıçtan sonra da sıralamış mesela
demişler ki ya demişler Ben e şurada
şurada bir yerde denizin ortasında
kayboldum yönümü nasıl tarif edebilirim
yerimi nasıl bulacak Kime nasıl tarif
edebilirim demişler dünyanın ötesindeki
bir insana yerimi nasıl tarif edebilirim
ve çizgiler koymuşlar demişler ki ya o
zaman bir çizgi koyalım şöyle dik bir
çizgi koyalım o çizgiyi söyleyelim o
çizgiye gelsin tamam koyalım Mesela
şöyle dik bir çizgi buldum Bakın şu
çizgiyi koyduk Mesela 10 şöyle 10 Doymuş
10 doğ mereni 10 Doğu çizgisi diyelim
meridyeni bilmiyorsun Sen şimdi 10 Doğu
çizgisinde yim dedi bana tamam Yerini
tarif edecek E şimdi ben Hocam geldim 10
Doğu çizgisini buldum bakın 10 Doğu
çizgisi şurası buldum tamam bu adamı
buldum mu bulamadım Niye ya bu 10 Doğu
çizgisinin her yerinde olabilir şurası
da 10 Doğu çizgisi e Güney Yarım küreye
geliyorum bakın Burası da 10 Doğu
çizgisi E o zaman şu 10 Doğu çizgisinin
her yerinde olabilir bu ha demişler O
zaman sadece bir dikey çizgi koyarak
bunu tespit edemeyiz O zaman bir de
yatay çizg koymamız lazım yatay
çizgilerde çizmişler o zaman demişler ki
arkadaş 10 Doğu çizgisinde yim ama bir
de 10 Doğu dik çizgisinde yim ama bir de
yatay bir çizgideyim 30 bakın şurada 30
Kuzey çizgisinde demişler şöyle biraz
daha geri ha 30 Kuzey çizgisi ve 10 Doğu
çizgisinin birleştiği yerdeyim bak 10
Doğu çizgisini buldum 30 Doğu çizgisini
buldum O zaman nokta atışı 10 doğuyla
bakın görüyor musunuz yaklaştım
Yaklaştım yaklaştım 10 Doğu la 30'u tam
30'u bulalım 10 doğuyla 30'un noktasını
buldum adamı nokta atışı buldum gördünüz
mü 10 Doğu dik çizgisiyle 30 Kuzey yatay
çizgisinde deyince buldum adamı işte
Gençler bu çizgiler Bu yüzden oluşturur
coğrafi koordinat dediğimiz şeyler
bunlar yatay ve dikey çizgiler İşte biz
bu çizgilere dikey olanlara merdiven
diyoruz A pardon pardon meridyen diyoruz
meridyenler Merdivenler Merdivenler
dikey çizgiler merdiveni dikey
koyarsınız değil mi paraleller paralar
paralar dik durur mu Durmaz paralar
yatay durur paral paral paralel paralar
yatay çizgiler demişti paraleller ve
meridyenler ortaya çıkmış gelelim notumu
şimdi paraleller ve meridyenler diye
anlattım ya sana geçmişte gençler
müfredat yenilenmeden önce paraleller ve
meridyenleri ayrıntılı işleyip bunların
özelliklerini de öğreniyorduk ama artık
yeni müfredatta paralel ve meridyenler
işlemeyin bizim için değerde olan enlem
ve
boylamlarda Ama ben bunları notlara
koydum okumak isteyen okusun
öğretmenlerinizin bazıları hala bunları
da anlatabilir O yüzden öğretmenlere
koydum bunları Ama ben olsam Benim
tavsiyem Öğretmen arkadaşlar dinliyorsa
paralel ve meridyenleri anlatmayın
arkadaşlar bunların özelliklerini böyle
ezberletme çocuklara ben yine de nota
koydum çünkü kitabımızda MEB
müfredatında artık bunların bir anlamı
kalmadı tamam artık neyin anlamı kaldı
enlemin boylamın anlamı kaldı hocam
enlem ve boylam ne demek şimdi Gelelim
asıl konumuza şimdi gençler paralel
meridyenleri çizdik ya biz Ama bunlar
yeterli değil Çünkü geliyorum ben mesela
geldim şimdi Bak geldim şöyle bir tane
daha şimdi geldim bak 40 Kuzey paraleli
bu tamam mı Şöyle daha net görünsün diye
denizin üstüne gelim bakın 40 Kuzey
paraleli 41 Kuzey paraleli bana dedi ki
şimdi E ben 40' la ya da 41 Kuzey
paralelinin üstünde değilsem Şu arada
bir yerdeyem Çünkü iki tane paralel
arasında kaç kilometre var biliyor
musunuz 111 km var ya Şu arada şuradan
şuraya giderken 111 km var E Ya ben
bunların arasında bir yerdeyem 111
kilometrelik bir yer beni Nasıl bulsun
111 kilometrelik bir yer bulamazlar
değil mi o yüzden paralel ve
meridyenlerden ziyade bizim için enlem
ve boylamlar önemli Enlem ne demek enlem
enine çizgi demek boylam boyuna çizgi
demek Ama enlem ve boylamın özelliği şu
enlem bir yerin ekvatora açı cinsinden
değeri bu önemli değil bu Tan senin için
enlem ekvatora açı cinsinden Bunu unutma
ama enlemi Demek ki enlemi ekvatora göre
belirliyoruz ne demek bu bize ne
sağlıyor daha da ayrıntıya girebilmem
sağlıyor bak küçük küçük görüyor musunuz
bak küçük küçük Bak ne diyor biraz daha
yaklaşım çok yaklaştık bak enleme bak 40
görüyor musunuz 40 derece 13 dakika 10
saniye Kuzey ne North kuzey kuzey enlemi
işte enlem çok daha ayrıntısını veriyor
bize nereye kadar kadar ayrıntısı
saniyesine kadar nokta atışı ayrıntısını
veriyor bize bu yüzden bizim için
enlemler ve boylamlar önemli bu yüzden
bir yerin tarifi yapılırken de enlem ve
boylamları la tarifi yapılır Şimdi ben
direkt evimin tarifini yapmayayım size
ama Geldim Türkiye'ye geldim Türkiye'de
görev yaptığım Erciş'te görev yapmıştım
ben gençler 2014 yılında Erciş'e atandım
4 yıl orada görev yaptım orada görev
yaptığım Okulu bulayım hem de orada
öğrenciler de varsa oradan takip eden
tokilerde kalıyordum toki'yi mi bulsam
acaba L Buralar bayağı gelişmiş Ya ha şu
taraftaydı Tokiler ha Tam şurada şu cami
vardı Ben de e Adan Menderes İlkokulu
vardı Evet şunun arkasından yürüyordum
tam şuradaydı Evet yok tam şurada şurada
kalıyordum Evet tam burası arabamı da
şuraya çekiyordum Benim araba var mı
Yoksa eski bir görüntü mü bu Belki de şu
benim kırmızıydı Neyse şimdi bakın
Şuraya bir nokta koyacağım geldim
arabamı Şu kırmızı arabanın benim
olduğunu varsayalım arabamın yerini
koydum bakın dikkat etmenizi istiyorum
sizden konuma Ne yazdı Görüyor musunuz
bak 39
derece 0 Dakika 58 saniye Kuzey
enleminde ben bir de boylam var şimdi
sadece enine çizgiye göre yerimi tarif
edemem Bir de boyuna çizgiye göre tarif
etmem lazım ne demek boyuna çizgiler de
var dünyada Bak enine çizgiler vardı
boyuna boyuna da boyun Hanın başlangıcı
bak enenin başlangıcı ekvatoru boyuna
çizgilerin başlangıcı da Greenwich
Londra'dan geçiyor Greenwich Tamam ona
göre oraya yapan Greenwich geçen
başlangıç boylamına oluşan açı değerine
de boylam diyor bir de boyuna çizgisini
söylemem lazım Benim buranın geldim
bakın 43 dce 24 dakika 32 saniye doğu
boylamı neden Doğu bu sefer oldu gençler
bakın şuraya ekvatoru böldük
kuzeydekiler Kuzey enlemleri güneydeki
Güney enlemleri diyoruz biz aynı şekilde
boylamları da bölerken bir tane sıfıra
ihtiyacımız var Bu sıfırımı da Şuradaki
Londra'dan geçen Greenwich bir gün ben
greenwich'in istiyorum bir gün gidince
Türkiye'ye dolaşıyoruz Bir sene sonra
yurt dışında da böyle 10 günlük geziler
yapmayı düşünüyorum Böyle çok istediğim
yerlere greenwich'in diğimi şöyle orası
sıfır E şimdi greenwich'in bu
tarafındakiler Doğu e batısındaki de
Batı bakın greenwich'in doğusundaki Doğu
boylamları boy boyuna uzanıyor
batısındaki Batı boylamları bak ne oldu
boyuna uzandı buraya geldim Ekvator
Ekvator'un
kuzeyindeki çizilmiş Kuzey enlemleri
güneyindeki Güney enlemleri enlem boylu
budur işte ne işe yarar saniyesine kadar
bizim yerimizi bulmamızı sağlar gelelim
notumu enlem boylamın mantığı budur
gençler notta Sana bunu nasıl soracak
yani öğretmenin Sana bunu nasıl soracak
sana bununla alakalı tam olarak şunu
isteyecek senden aslında hiç
zorlanacağını bir yerin coğrafi
koordinatını bana bul diyecek bu coğrafi
koordinatı bulmayı göstereceğim şimdi
sana sınav sorunda bu zaten az önce
anlattıklarım kafanda bir mantığın otur
masını sağlamak için tamam mı enlem niye
var boylam niye var dünya üzerindeki o
kürede enlemler boylamlar nerede bunları
bulabilmenin le alakalıydı şimdi geldim
etkinlikle beraber bunu pekiştirelim
etkinliğe geçmeden önce atladığımız bir
şey var mı diye bakayım bunları gpsler
de kullanıyoruz Bu arada değil mi GPS
bize bunları otomatik olarak veriyor
işte bir de şunu da göstereyim sana
çünkü sorular da karşımıza çıkabiliyor
bunun mantığını öğrenin mesela bakın 50
60 70 diye gidiyor değil mi Bunlar
boylam boyuna çizgiler Tamam peki Bun
Doğu boylamları mı Batı boylamı bunu
bulabiliyorsun nereden buluyorsun Şimdi
sen 50 60 diye bu tarafa doğru gidiyor
değil mi 0'ı Nereye koyarsın Buraya mı
koyarsın Hayır şimdi 0 60 50 a ters oldu
değil mi 0 nereye koyarsın buraya
koyarsın ha 50 60 Demek ki 0 bu tarafta
e 0 buradaysa bu taraftakiler batıda
kaldı Batı boylamları Bunlar Demek ki
sana böyle sayılarına bakarak batıda mı
doğuda mı bulabiliyorsun buna bakalım 50
60 He 0 bu tarafta bu taraftan başlamış
He o zaman Bunlar doğuda kalmış diyorsun
bakın Doğu e Bunlar dik çizgi boy boyuna
çizilmiş boylam aynı şey enlemlerde de
var şurada Mesela geldim 50 60 0 nerede
He 0 üstte kaldı o zaman 0 50 60 70 diye
gidecek o zaman bunlar nerede kaldı
Bunlar güneyde kaldı değil mi o zaman
Bunlar Güney şöyle sıfır Güney Güney ne
enlem enine çizilmiş Güney enlemleri
dersin buna şunun ismini ne diye
yazarsın 50 Güney enlemi dersin 0 50 60
He 0 Demek ki burada bunlar nerede kaldı
kuzeyde O zaman şunu Yaz dersem sana
dersin ki hocam 60 Kuzey enleme Böylece
hangi kuzeyde mi batıda mı doğuda mı
olduğunu bulabiliyoruz Tamam geldim
buraya Şimdi asıl önemli olan şey Burası
Çünkü ne dedim sana müfredatını
güncellendi güncellenen müfredatta en
değerli şey ne dedim Bir yerin konumunu
bulabilmenin Hayatta bunu yapabilmen
Bunun için de gel örneklerle bunu
öğrenelim nasıl yapabileceğimizi mesela
bakın bize Aydın'ı örnek olarak vermiş
demiş ki 37 d 30 dakika kuzeyde hemen 35
36 37'ye buldum bak 37 arada bir de 30
diyor Demek ki şu arası da yarım şöyle
bak ben şöyle Yaklaştır yarım 37 30
yarısı Tamam bu çizgiyi Çizeceksin bunu
buldun mu çizdin Bir de diyor ki ama
sadece 37 30' da bulamazsın bu çizginin
her yerinde olabilir Bir de diyor ki
boylamına boyuna bak 28 D 0 Dakika ha
Tam 28'in üstündeymiş o zaman 28 Doğuyu
26 27 28'i buldum bakın boylam dediği
için bakın şurada boylam dediği için
boyuna çizgilere bakıyorum 28'i buldum
boyuna çizgiyi çizdim bak kesiştiği yer
neresi Aydın He burası aydınmış dedin
Aydın'ı yazdın Buna göre bu etkinlikleri
yapalım şimdi seninle map kitabında da
bu etkinlik var aynısını yapıyorsun
Tamam öğretmenin le burada öğrendin
şimdi öğreniyorsun öğretmenin le
yapacaksın geldim hepsini yapmayayım 2ü
tane yapayım mantığını anla sonra
şuradan Ekran görüntüsü al şöyle tablet
takip ediyorsan Ekran görüntüsü al
Benimle beraber yap ya da ben hepsini
yapmayacağım diğerlerini sen doldur
tamam şimdi geldim mesela şuna bakalım
3645 Kuzey enlemine bakacağım ha enine
çizgilerden 36'yı bulacağım enine
çizgiler Bunlar 36'yı buldum hocam 36'yı
buldum bana diyor ki 36 45'i bul He 36
30 Burası hocam 36 45 de burada bir
yerde olur değil mi tam o kadar
ayrıntılı vermemiş haritada şöyle bir
çizdim Tamam sonra diyor ki 28 boy
lamına dikine bak ha 28 dike baktım 15
dakikalık olacak 28'in şurası 30'unu
oluştursa 15 de bunların arasında olacak
ikisinin arasında olacak indirdim Nereye
denk geldi Tam kesiştiği yere
bakacaksınız Muğla'ya denk geldi Demek
ki burası muğl mış Anladık mı Nasıl
yapacağımızı bir örnek daha yapalım
gelin Şimdi sildim bakalım şuradan 39 40
dakika kuzeyi bul diyor bak Kuzey enine
çizgi olacak Tamam hocam enine çizgilere
bakacağım Bu 39 olacak enine çizgileri
de 39 burada buldum bak Bir de diyor ki
40 dakika olacak Demek ki biraz 40'a
yaklaşacak Şuradaki 30 arasındaki 30
30'un biraz üstü olacak kaba taslak
yapıyorum bak çizdim buldum çizgiyi
Tamam şimdi dikini bulalım boylamını 30
boyuna çizgisini bul diyor 30 boyuna
çizgisini buldum Sonra diyor bunun 30
dakikalık yarısını şurası 30 Burası 31
ya yarısı Burası 30 dakikalığına bul
diyor buldum ikisini işaretledim çıkmadı
ya Ben de diyorum niye çıkmadı 30 30'un
30'unu bul derken şuraya bakmışım ben en
üsttekine şuraya bakmışım burada değildi
ki Bizimki şuradaydı
05 dakikasına bak yani 30 dakikaya kadar
gitme Hemen şurası 30 dakikaya diyor Ben
de diyorum niye çıkmıyor bu ya Hemen
şurada 30'un hemen yanını işaretle diyor
bana tamam 0 5'ine gidiyorsun Ben
diyorum niye çıkmadı bakın neymiş Bunun
ismi Kütahya mış gördük mü Hemen buraya
Kütahya yazdık Nasıl bulduğumu
anlatabiliyor muyum bir örnek daha
yapalım Şu 8 kısmı yapalım
senin ekran görüntüsünü al İlk önce bir
bul bakalım doğru mu yapacaksın Sonra
benimle izle 37 bak adım adım göstereyim
Bir daha diyor ki 37'ye bul ama neyin
37'si enine çizgilerin 37'si Tamam enine
çizgiler Bunlar enine çizgilerin 37'si
Burada 30 Dakikasını bul 38 ile 37'nin
tam arası 30 dakika Tamam o zaman bu
çizgiyi buldum çizdim sonra diyor ki bir
de boyuna çizgiyle bunu bulmam lazım
tamam 30 boyuna çizgiyi bul boyuna
çizgiler Bunlar 30 boyuna çizgi Burası
diyor ki onun da 30 Dakikasını al tam
yarısı şurası değil mi Bunu da çizdim
tam kesiştikleri yer Isparta oldu buna
da ısparta'yı yazdım Tamam böyle böyle
tek tek hepsini yapmaya kalkarsam bir
saat sadece Bunları yapma olur O yüzden
sen ekran görüntüsünü al ben sana burayı
çizdim şimdi ekran görüntüsünü alıyorsun
tek tek hepsini yapıyorsun tamam mı
olmazsa okul kitabında da bu etkinlik
var çünkü okulda öğretmenine
dolduracaksın büyük bir ihtimalle okul
kitabındaki etkinliğini de yapabilirsin
buraya kadar Tamam mıyız Evet şimdi
geldik nereye hocam ya biz bak hep
günlük hayatla alakalı şeyleri öğ
öğrendik Aslında değil mi yani sen o
haritada yerini saniyesine kadar
birilerine anlatabiliyorsa O bizim
kullandığımız telefonlarda GPS
sistemleri var değil mi yolda giderken
yerimizi haritamızı Bütün her şeyimizi
gösteren bir yerden bir yere giderken
harita uygulamaları kullanıyoruz gençler
GPS sistemleri işte orayı kullanın Sen
artık bunu biliyorsun Günlük hayatta
GPS'i Aslında hangi sistemi kullandığını
nasıl bir işe yaradığını enlemlerin
boylamların Ne olduğunun mantığını
kullandın öğrendin kullanarak öğrendin
haritanın ne olduğunu öğrendin Şimdi bir
de hocam yani biz namaz kılıyoruz oruç
tutuyoruz İşte Cuma namazına gideceğiz
sabah namazı kılıyoruz ya oruç tutacağız
ya bir bakıyoruz Hocam biz ya
Edirne'deki adam orucunu daha erken
açıyor ama İstanbul'da biz orucumuzu
daha geç açıyoruz Ya arkadaş saat
herkesin saati değil mi ya Saat Bende de
aynı saat se e herkeste de aynı saat
olmalı niye O benden önce açıyor bu
haksızlık değil mi diye kafanda bazı
günlük hayatta kullandığın saatlerle
alakalı bazı problemler oluşuyor ama bu
problemler günlük hayatta çok oluşmuyor
daha çok namazlar Oruç Bu dönemlerde
oluşuyor hocam böyle bir şey neden
oluşuyor gençler yerel saat diye bir şey
var ne demek hocam yerel saat Aslında
her yerin saati farklıdır Şu an ben
mesela saate bakıyorum tamam mı saatim
bu videoyu çekerken 3.5 İstanbul'da
yaşıyorum saatim 3,5 haritayı açayım Sen
şimdi geldim ben şimdi şurada Şuradaki
noktadayım tamam mı İstan Silivri'de
yaşıyorum Silivri'de im ben Silivri'ye
noktayı koydum ben şimdi Silivri'de
yaşıyorum saatim 3.3 Mesela sen de en
son gezimizi orduya yapmıştık Tamam mı
orduda Tam da şuralarda yason burnunda
yason kilisesinin oralarda olduğunu
varsayalım şimdi E diğeri gitti He
kaydetmek mi gerekiyor Neyse sen
buradasın saatine bakıyorsun şu an seni
arasam Senin de saatin 3,5 E benim de
saatim 3,5 herkesin saati 3,5 mu Aslında
hayır herkesin saati farklı gençler
Nasıl farklı şöyle Aslında Her meridyen
arasında 4 dakikalık bir zaman farkı
oluşuyor şöyle söyleyeyim size her
boylam arasında 4 dakikalık zaman farkı
var şimdi bakın bir sürü boylam var
burada değil mi Şu tarafı gör görürseniz
karanlık gençler dünya batıdan doğuya
doğru dönüyor şöyle şu tarafta güneş
olduğunu varsayın tamam mı Şuradaki
çizgiler Şuradaki boylamlar güneşin
karşısından daha önce geçiyorlar şimdi
güneşin karşısından Sen daha önce
geçtiğinde Güneş sende daha önce doğuyor
ne demek hocam Şurayı varsayalım Şurayı
Şimdi burası bir dakika şunu kapatalım
şimdi Güneş şuradan vuruyor tamam mı
buradan vuruyor şuraya vurdu Güneş
Burada doğdu saat 6 Her meridyen
arasında yakınlaş şu meridyenden bak 90
meridyen demeye alıştık boylam diyelim
artık 990 boylam 89 boylam şimdi Güneş
biraz geri geleyim ha Güneş Burada doğdu
mu doğdu değil mi şimdi güneşin
karşısına Burası gelecek geldi kaç
dakika geçti biliyor musun 4 dakika
geçti şununla şunun arasında 4 dakikalık
bir zaman farkı var Aslında bundan buna
gidene kadar 4 dakikalık bir zaman farkı
var Aslında bundan buna gidene kadar 4
dakikalık bir zaman farkı var aslında 4
dakika şimdi ben bunun gibi 15 tane
geçsem 15 tane geçtiğimizi varsayalım 15
x 4 60 dakika dakika bir saat Yani
aslında 15 tane meriden geçsem boylam
geçsem 1 saatlik bir zaman farkı
oluşuyor gelelim Şimdi Türkiye'ye şimdi
bakın şurası 45 Görüyor musun bak şu
45'ten Şuradaki 30'a kadar bak
Türkiye'nin bir ucundan diğer bir
tarafına kadar İzmit'e kadar 15 meridyen
geçti 1 saat geçti yani aslında
Türkiye'deki buradaki 45'ten bu tarafa
kadar 1 saatlik bir zaman farkı olması
lazım ama niye ben burada saate bakarım
baktığımda saat 3.30 görüyorken
Iğdır'daki kişi de niye 3.5 görüyor
herkes de 3 bu5 görüyor Çünkü gençler
herkesin yerel saati farklı aslında işte
burada yerel saat ve ortak saat devreye
giriyor Burası 6'yı 88 geçiyorsa Burası
4 geçiyor burası 6 burası işte
556 4 dakika 4 dakika geride hepsi niye
bu taraf ileride Çünkü güneşin
karşısından ilk Burası geçiyor Doğu
tarafımız güneşin karşısından ilk orası
geçiyor O yüzden saat burada her zaman
daha ileri Burada saat 8 ise İstanbul'da
saat daha geri işte bir saat geride
diyelim Burada saat 8 ise Burada saat 7
ir herkesin saati farklıdır Aslında
herkesin yerel saati Ama neden yerel
saat oluştu Çünkü boylam var ve her
boylam arasında 4 dakikalık zaman farkı
var Peki hocam Demek ki şunu anladık şu
boylamda saat 6'yı 4 geçiyorsa şu
boylamda saat 6 şu boylamda saat 556 Şu
boylamda 5.52 4 dakikayla gidiyor ve her
boylamın yerel saati farklıymış Bunlar
Yerel saatler şunu da öğrenmen lazım
mantıken öğrenmen lazım ama şu boylama
bakar mısın bu boylam güneşin
karşısından aynı anda geçmeyecek mi Evet
burada saat 6 olduğunu varsayalım tamam
mı 6 bu boylamda kuzeyde de saat 6
Türkiye'de de saat 6 Etiyopya'da da saat
6 aynı boylamda bak Çünkü aynı anda
güneşin karşısından geçiyorlar bak
Dikkat et aynı anda geçiyorlar güneşin
karşısına O yüzden bir boylamın üstünde
saat kaçsa dünyanın neresinde olursa
olsun bu boylam malavi'de de olsa burada
Güney Afrika Cumhuriyeti'nde de olsa bu
boylam aynı boylamın üzerindeki saatleri
hepsi aynıdır ama bu boylamın biraz
doğusuna biraz batısına gittiğimizde
boylamlar arasında 4 dakika olduğu için
artık saatler değişir Biz de buna Yerel
saatler diyoruz Tamam mantık bu şimdi
böyle size ayrıntılı anlatmaya
çalışıyorum ki kafanızda yer etsin
gençler Eğer böyle anlatmazsam öyle
lambur lumbur anlatıp geçersem
anlayamazsınız E zaten Okulda da belki
anlayamayacaksınız bu dersi kaçırdınız
vesaire burada
tamamlayabilir şey bilmiyormuşsun gibi
anlatmak zorundayım İnşallah anlat
bilmişimdir kafanızda az da olsa yer
etmiştir yerel saatin tam tanımına
Gelecek olursak dünya üzerindeki bir
yerde güneşin tam tepe noktasında olduğu
an 12 olarak kabul edilir işte ona göre
de saati ayarladığımız da oranın yerel
saatini bulmuş oluruz yani tam tepeye
12'de gelir her yerde öyledir tam tepeye
saat 12'de gelir Güneş O da oranın yerel
saatini verir Bize tamam Bakın şurası
önemli bunu anlattım sana az önce
Aslında Güneş doğuda daha erken doğar
Hakkari'de saat bakın 12.30 Muğla da
saat 11.30 arada saat farkı var Hakkari
daha doğuda olduğu için saat orada daha
ileri tamam Bakın gençler şurada
Osmaniye'de Güneş tam tepede diyagramın
tam tepesine güneşi koyduğunda Güneş tam
tepede demek diyagramın bakın şöyle bir
diyagram verdiğinde bize diyagramın daha
böyle bu tarafına koymuş Bu demek ki
güneş daha burada Tepe noktaya gelmemiş
demek Tamam o zaman burası daha batıda
bir yerde demektir Çünkü Güneş daha
tepeye gelmemiş bakın Hakkari'nin
diyagramına bakın şöyle Güneş tepeye
gelmi
12 olmuş saat güneş tepeden gitmiş Artık
akşama doğru gidiyor Demek ki burası
daha doğuda bir yerde Çünkü güneş doğmuş
artık batış doğru gidiyor tamam mı bunun
mantığını şöyle göstereyim size bir de
Çünkü şöyle diyagramlar veriyor bize
Bunların hangisi daha doğudadır Mesela
bu mu daha doğudadır bu mu daha
doğudadır diye bul Bakalım bunu diyor
bize hemen ne yapacaksın biliyor musun
Güneş tepede 1200 yani şurada Tepe ha
Tepeyi geçmiş Burada Güneş diyeceksin
Tepeyi geçmesi için Güneş Burada doğmuş
batmaya gidiyor demek ki He burası o
zaman daha doğuda bir yerde Çünkü güneş
doğmuş buna bakıyorum Güneş daha Tepe
noktasına ulaşmamış diyeceksin ha Güneş
yeni yeni doğuyor diyeceksin e yeni yeni
doğuyorsa bu daha batıda bir yerde
güneşin karşısına geçememiş diyeceksin
Burası daha batıda bak Londra Şurada
daha batıda e Rusya bu tarafta daha
doğuda gördünüz mü Bunun mantığı bu bu
grafikleri yorumlamanın mantığı bu
bunları öğrettik Şimdi geldik asıl
önemli olan kısma ortak saate az önce
bir sorunun cevabını vermedim size Neydi
bu soru hocam E hocam sende Saat 3.30
Ordu'da da saat 3.30 hepimiz şu an aynı
anda saate baksak Ordu'da da saat 3.
Diyarbakır'da da Hakkari'de de
İstanbul'da da saat 3.0 Bu nasıl oluyor
Hani her yerin saati farklıydı şimdi her
yerin saati farklı olursa karışıklık
olmaz mı Gençler düşünün Şimdi
türkiye'deyiz biz Hakkari diyor ki ya
Benim saatim 8 İstanbul'dayım ben Ya
diyorum ki arkadaşım ne saatin 8 olması
Benim saatim 7 öyle bir şey yok mesela
biz bunu yaşıyoruz bu sıkıntıları değil
mi oruçta yaşıyoruz mesela namazda
yaşıyoruz Hakkari'deki E daha erken
kılıyor namazını Biz daha geç kılıyoruz
arada zaman farkı var O karışıklıklar
oluşuyor İşte o karışıklıkların devlet
dairelerinde iletişimde yaşandığını bir
düşünün namazı orucu bir kenara
bırakalım devlet dairelerinde ve
iletişimde yaşandığını düşünün problem
olur değil mi İşte bu problemler olmasın
diye ne yapıyorlar biliyor musunuz
Türkiye'de mesela diyorlar ki ya bir
tane yer belirleyelim o yerin saatini
ortak saat yapalım diyelim ki ya Biz
Iğdır'ı belirledik Bundan sonra herkes
saatini Biz Iğdır'ı Ortak belirledik
herkes için ortak belirledik Iğdır'ın
saatini bundan sonra ortak saat
yapıyoruz diyorlar herkes saatini ileri
ya da geri alıp Iğdır'ın saatine göre
ayarlıyor ve Aslında ben şu an saate
baktığımda kimin saatine bakıyorum
biliyor musunuz şu an sen Saate
bakıyorsun ya o Kimin saati biliyor
musun Iğdır'ın saati Evet şu an biz
ortak saat olarak Iğdır'ın saat kullanı
Eskiden İzmit'in saatini kullanıyorduk
hem İzmit'in hem Iğdır'ın saatini
kullanıyorduk E peki Hocam niye Iğdır'ın
Onu da göstereyim mantığını şimdi bakın
15 meridyende bir 15 boylamda bir saat
var değil mi Çünkü 15 tane boylam 4 le
çarp yapınca bir saat yapıyor şimdi
bakın Iğdır'dan geçiyor 45 45 bak 15'in
katı 45 Bir de şurada 30 vardı İzmit'ten
geçiyordu bu 30' la 45 hep bir saat bak
15'te bir saat var Bunları kullanıyorduk
Biz bir dönemde İzmit'i bir dönemde
Iğdır'ı kullanıyorduk işte kışın İzmit'e
göre ayarlıyım herkes saatini geri ya da
ileri alıyordu Bilmiyorum belki yaşınız
tutar mı hatırlıyor musunuz bir dönem
geliyordu herkes saatini bir geri bir
saat geri alıyordu Bir dönüm geliyordu
herkes saatini bir saat ileri alıyordu
böyle şeyler yapıyorduk sonra geçti bu
yakın zamanda dedi ki ya bu olmuyor
böyle bir saat ileri bir saat geri
sadece 45'i kullanacağız dedik Şu an
sadece 45'i kullanıyoruz yani 45'in
boylamındaki saat kaçsa onu kullanıyoruz
Biz ortak Şu an ben aslında 45
boylamındaki Doğu boylamındaki saate
bakıyorum ben İstanbul'dayım Normalde
benim 45'e değil kaç var burada 29'a
bakmam lazım Ama karışıklık olmasın diye
45 doğ boylamındaki saate bakıyoruz
hepimiz ortak olarak 45'i kullanıyoruz
bir tane ortak saatimiz var bizim
Anlaştık mı İşte ortak saat de bu ortak
saatin mantığı bu bizim ülkemizde bir
tane ortak saat var Amma ve lakin bazı
ülkelerde daha fazla ortak saat olmak
zorunda kalıyor neden ya şimdi Amerika
gibi bir ülkeye bakın Hadi bizim ülkemiz
o kadar geniş değil Arada zaten bizim o
kadar zaman farkı yok ama bu Amerika
gibi bir ülkede dünya kadar zaman farkı
oluşuyor arada var Belki de 8 saatlik
zaman farkı o zaman doğu batı yönündeki
ülkeler bir tane ortak saat kabul
kullanamıyor gençler diyorlar ki ya bir
tane ortak saat saat kullansak nasıl
olacak Düşünsenize şuranın ortak saatini
varsayalım saat burada 12 diyelim burada
7 daha burada Belki gece olmuş 0300
Olmuş sadece şu 12'yi kabul edebilirler
mi Şuradaki adama diyeceksin ki saatini
öğlen 12'ye ayarla La gece nasıl öylen
12'yi ayarlayayım Diyecek o yüzden doğu
batı yönündeki ülkeler geniş ülkeler
yani doğu batı yönünde böyle çok geniş
ülkeler sadece bir tane ortak saat
kullanamıyor ne yapıyorlar iki tane 3
tane 4 tane 5 tane ortak saat
kullanıyorlar bunlar bir tanesi Amerika
mesela bakın kaç 6 adet ortak saat
kullan belirlemiş Buradakiler bir ortak
saat Buradakiler bir ortak saat
Buradakiler bir ortak Saate göre hareket
ediyorlar Demek ki doğu batı yönündeki
ülkeler çok fazla ortak saat kullanıyor
böyle bir soru gelebilir karşımıza ülke
verir Bize hangisi daha fazla ortak saat
kullanır hangisi daha az kullanır
genelde de şiliy veriyor çünkü Şili
bakalım şöyle bakın geldik Şili Burası
görüyor musunuz içinde bir tane
neredeyse boylam geçecek ya Yani Kuzey
Güney yönünde uzanan bir ülke Şili O
yüzden içinden çok fazla boylam geçmiyor
çok fazla boylam geçmediği için de çok
fazla saatlerle öyle işi olmuyor bir
tane saati ortak belirleyince
kurtarabiliyor Ama sen gelip Amerika
gibi bir ülke ya buradan buraya kadar
nasıl bir tane ortak saat kullanın
kullanamıyorsun Bu soru sana ülkelerin
yerini bilmekten sorulacak Yani şöyle
diyecek ki sana hangi ülke daha çok
ortak saat kullanabilir diye soracak
bunu bilebil için ülkelerin yerini
bilmen lazım bizim bir tane ücretsiz
uygulamamız var ücretsiz Türkiye'deki
illerin yerini de oynayarak
öğrenebiliyor gorsun ülkelerin yerini de
Google'a ios'a coğrafyanın kodları
yazarsanız çıkar karşınıza coğrafyanın
kodları yazın çıkıyor zaten hemen oyun
onu indirin otobüste gidip gelirken
Türkiye'deki şehirleri oynayın dünyadaki
ülkelerin yerini oynayın öğrenin zaten
bunu dünya haritaları kampımız da
öğrenmiştik onu izlemeden 9 sınıf
öğrencisi olamazsın 7 günlük kamp dünya
haritalarını bitir ulusal ortak saati de
öğrendik mi Evet Şuradaki Notları da bir
okuyalım bakın günümüzde Biz daha çok
yerel saatleri iftarda sahurda
namazlarda kullanıyoruz çok fazla
kullanmıyoruz Türkiye'nin ortak saati 45
Doğu meridyeninden geçiyor Bunu not al
altını çiz az önce zaten gösterdim sana
nereden Iğdır'dan 45 Doğu meridyenini
kullanıyoruz Tamam bunun da notunu aldık
şimdi Şurayı uluslararası saatleri
göstereceğim orada göstereyim size şu
kısmı bakalım bakın önceden 30 ve 45'i
kullanıyorduk anlattım Bunu sana Art 45
Doğuyu kullanıyoruz Bu da + 3 saat
diliminde yer alıyor Aslında biz + 3
saat dilimini kullanıyoruz şimdi bu
hocam benim günlük hayatta ne işime
yarayacak Ben olsam sorardım ama
coğrafyada soramazsın Neden Çünkü
hayatın tam için hiç internette bir iş
yaparken bir şey yaparken karşına
çıkmadı mı Mesela oyunlar oynuyorsun
değil mi İnternet üzerinden orada burada
bir şeylerde bir yerlerde hiç böyle ı 3
saat ı 2 saat dilim diye karşına çıkmadı
mı Google ayarlarını falan yaparken Neye
göre yapıyorsun ayarları ha diyeceksin
hocam -2 -5 + 1 Türkiye nerede + 3'te
Demek ki sen oralarda seçim yaparken
Google ayarlarında orada burada Seçim
yaparken o uygulama oyununu ayarlarken
falan + 3'ü seçeceksin Senin yerin + 3
neden + 3 ve bu + 3 ne anlama geliyor
hocam şimdi buna gelelim şimdi ne dedim
sana 15 tane meridyeni 4'le çarpınca bir
saat ortaya çıkıyor demiştim sana değil
mi Demek ki 15 meridyende bir saat
değişiyor bir saat dilimi oluşuyor İşte
buna göre dünyada 24 tane saat dilimi
oluşuyor dünya 24 saat dönüyor ve 24
tane saat dilimi var demek peki bunu
nereden Baş atıyoruz Nasıl oluyor bu iş
geliyoruz buraya bizim başlangıç boylam
mız nereden geçiyordu Greenwich
geçiyordu değil mi Londra'dan başlangıç
boylamı 0 gördük mü şöyle bu başlangıç
boylamının gençler 7,5 doğusunu 7,5 da
batısını almışlar 7,5 7,5 15 1 saat
diyor Heh işte buraya saat dilimlerinin
başlangıcı demişler Burası 0 saat dilim
geçtim sonraki kısım bakın + 1 saat
sonraki 15 meridyen + 2 saat sonraki 15
meridyen + 3 saat ilim bu tarafa
geliyorum bakın -1 niye -1 batıya
gidiyor bunlar doğuya gidiyor + 1 -1 -2
bakın Türkiye neredeydi + 3 saat
dilimini kullanıyordu ki + 3'e bakalım
bizimle beraber aynı saat dilimini
kullananlara bakalım bu haritada
bakamıyoruz bir hata var gençler
Normalde Türkiye'nin şöyle turuncuya
boyanmış olması gerekiyordu bu harita
hatalı ı 2 saat diliminde gösteriyor şu
an biz dikkat ederseniz yani hatayı bunu
söyleyeyim düzeltsinler Bizim Normalde
şurada turuncu bak bakın Bizim de
turuncu saat dilimini kullanıyor olmamız
gerekiyordu bakın bir hata var burada bu
hatayı İnşallah siz de fark
etmişsinizdir mantık bu böyle bakın 24
saat dilimimiz oluyor Evet bunu
öğrendik tarih değiştirme çizgisini de
anlatacağım sana sonra şurada saatle
alakalı + 3 + 9 saatle alakalı Biz soru
çözeceğiz şimdi tarih değiştirme çizgisi
diye bir şey var ne demek hocam tarihin
bir yerde değişmesi lazım değil mi Bugün
pazar yarın pazartesi herkes için pazar
mı bir taraf için Pazartesiye dönmüyor
mu Dünya dönerken tarih nerede değişiyor
dünyanın arka tarafına gidiyoruz arka
kısmına gidemiyoruz şu an geldik arka
kısmına dünyanın bakın şurada şurada şu
taraf Amerika şu taraf Asya Tam da
şurada Bering boğazı var dünya haraları
kampında izledik yani Bering boğazı'nı
öğrendik o kampı izleyin gençler 9 sınıf
olarak yapmanız gereken temel atmak için
ilk yapmanız gereken şey o burada Bering
boğazı'ndan geçiyor bu Bering boğazından
tarih değiştirme çizgisi geçiyor bu
Bering boğazından geçen tarih değiştirme
çizgi inin şu gördüğünüz bu
kısmındaki doğru olan
kısmındaki bu tarafta gün pazardır bu
tarafta gün Pazartesi E hocam Hani
doğuda gün ileriydi diyorsunuz ama
burası Doğu değil ki burası Amerika Batı
Burası Batı yarımküre Burası Doğu değil
Doğu olan yer burası yani burada gün
pazar ya burada güneşin karşısına
geçiyoruz Pazartesi oluyor sonra dönüyor
bakın pazartesiyi pazartesiyi
pazartesiye Amerika'da sonra pazartesi
oluyor Burası Pazartesi Ya şimdi burası
Pazartesi E bu bu tarafta salı
pazartesiden salıya geçiyoruz Demek ki
notumu dönelim Yani şöyle karşına
çıktığında bu taraf geri olacak bu taraf
ileri olacak bu taraf Çünkü Batı
yarımküre Aslında Amerika batıda sadece
tersten baktığımız için arka tarafa bu
taraf doğuda kalıyor Anlaştık mı demek
ki bunun Bu tarafın doğunun pazar gibi
görün geride görünmesinin nedeni bu
pazar pazartesi tamam bir de dikkat
etmenizi istediğim bir şey var nereden
geçiyor bu çizgi 180'den Çünkü 360 tane
meridyen var Tamam ortası 180 oluyor ne
demek Hocam yine orayı göstereyim size
mantığı tam otursun oturtmak istiyorum
mantığı bakın bizim başlangıcımız neydi
0 değil miydi Londra'dan 0dan geçmiyor
muydu E şimdi burada 180 tane Çünkü 360
şimdi Dünyanın etrafı 360 derece değil
mi o zaman ben 180 tane doğuya 180 tane
batıya çizebilirim Çünkü 180 buradan 180
tane de buradan 360 yapar 360 derece
olduğu için Dünyanın etrafı birer derece
aralıklarla çizdiğimde 360 dereceyi
bulurum E şimdi burası 0'sa bu sıfırın
tam karşısında anti meridyeni tam
karşısına dünyanın arka tarafına kalıyor
bir türlü düzeltemedim bakın arka tarafı
tersine kalmış oluyor buradaki mantığı
Anladık mı Niye 180'den geçtiğini Peki
hocam Onu anladık da niye böyle zikzaklı
geçiyor bu Çünkü şöyle düşün Mesela
şurada alaska'dan varsayalım bu Alaska
ABD'de tamam mı E Şuradaki Adalar da
Alaska'ya bağlı E şimdi sen bu çizgiyi
buradan getirip buradan geçirsen tam
buradan geçirsen düz bir şekil e şurada
Alaska'da Alaska ın bir Adası burada gün
olur sana pazartesi bu alaska'nın bu
taraftaki adasında gün olur sana pazar
karışıklık olur değil mi o yüzden
ülkeleri bölmem için ülkelerin
içerisinde böyle sorun olmasın diye
ülkelere göre ayırmışlar bunu buradan
geçirmişler Burası da pazara kalsın
alaska'nın bütün Adaları pazara kalsın
diye bu taraftakiler de böyle bakın
buradaki Adaları tek bir yerde tek bir
güne toplamaya çalışmışlar karışıklık
olmasın diye zikzaklar çizerek geçiyor
yani mantık bu bunun mantığını da
öğrendik mi tarih değiştirme çizgisini
de öğrendik mi Tamam şimdi gençler şöyle
şöyle soruyu görebiliyoruz değil mi
şimdi geçmişte buralarda Yerel saat
hesaplamaları yap yok işte şuranın
doğusunun batısında şu kadar saati
ileride geride olan yerin şuranın saati
kaçtır diye hesaplayın saçmalıktan öte
başka bir şey değildi ve bunu kaldırdı
müfredattan map Yani artık işlem o saat
hesaplamaları işlemleri istediğini
gösteren bir veri görmedik kitapta
sadece saat dilimlerini bil diyor sana
yani saat dilimini bil ki böyle bir
dünyada yaşıyorsun sen işte
İngiltere'den bir arkadaşım vardır
Amerika'dan bir Ark arkadaşın vardır Bu
Amerika'daki arkadaşının saat diliminin
Senden farklı olduğunu işte sen de
sabahken orada Aslında gece
olabileceğini ve ona göre bir saat
hesaplaması yapıp onunla irtibat kurman
gerekiyorsa o saat hesaplamasını kabaca
da olsa yapab yapmayı öğren demek
istiyor sana çok saat hesaplamasına
girme ama mantıken de olsa oranın saat
dilimini bir hesaplamayı öğrenebilir bil
diye söylüyor sana böyle bir mantıkla
anlatıyor mesela Ali arkadaşlarıyla aynı
anda internet üzerinden görüntülü olarak
görüşme yapacaktır Amerika'daki
arkadaşınla görüşeceğim Ali'nin arkadaşı
Can New York'ta belk ise Tokyo'da yer
almak şöyle Yakınlaştır alım şimdi buna
göre konuşma Türkiye saatiyle 16'da
olacak ha Türkiye şurada saat
16.00'da olacak saat konuşma başladığı
anda şimdi hepiniz anlaştınız şimdi
dedin ki New York'taki arkadaşına saat
dedin 16'da buluşalım arkadaş Senin
saatin 16'da onun saati 16 değil ki
nasıl ayarlayacağız bunu bakalım
yaşadığı şeylerin ulusal saatleri
onların saati hangisinde doğru olarak
verilmiştir Yani sen 16'da ekran başına
geçtiğinde onların saati kaç acaba şimdi
bakın Ali kaçıncı saat diliminde + 3
saat diliminde değil mi mantıken
bulabileceğim bir şey Bu işlem yapmana
gerek yok mantık sorusu Bu ber kaçıncı
saat diliminde + 9 saat diliminde şimdi
+ 3 saat dilimi + 9 saat dilimi arada
kaç saat dilimi var 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 arada
6 tane saat dilimi var değil mi Yani 6
saat dilimi var arada 6 saat var arada e
alide saat kaç 16:00 Şimdi 6 saat var
arada Burası da Tokyo e Tokyo daha
ileride saati Çünkü güneşin karşısında
daha önce değil mi daha ileride o zaman
saati O zaman saat şeyde Ali'nin 16 İsa
6 saat koyacağım üstüne bu kadar 17 18
19 20 21 22 olacak tokyo'daki saat Bak
aslında bir mantık sorusu hesaplama diye
bir şey yapmıyorum ha hemen sayısala
girdim diye erroru vermeyin o zaman 22
olmayanları sildim Tamam geldim bu
tarafa Tamam bunu şöyle yaptım şimdi
şöyle yakınlaştım Ali + 3 saat diliminde
Can -4 Bak burada sadece dikkat etmeni
gereken bir şey var burada bir sıfır var
tam orada değil de şuraya kayıyor da
ortaya doğru koyayım 0 yani burada 3
tane var + 3 ya Bu da -4 burada da 7
tane var ne 7'si ya ikisini topladım
kafamda 4 tane var niye sıfırdan geçtim
yani 3 tane bu tarafta var 4 tane de
burada var eksi artı matematikten
biliyorsunuzdur O kadarını Demek ki
burada kaç tane saat dilimi var 7 tane
saat geçeceğim Yani saat 16'dan 7 saat
geri geleceğim 16 15 14 13 12 11 19 Bak
bu kadar basit 9A Geldim Nerede o 9 Heh
burada can 9 cevab Ha Burada bakın işlem
yapmadım Sadece bir mantık sorusu çözdüm
MEB'in de bizden istediği Aslında bu
bizden şöyle bir işlem istemiyor eskiden
olduğu gibi işte İstanbul'da saat şunda
şu boylamda saat kaçtır gibi saçma sapan
iş istemiyor Lütfen coğrafya öğretmeni
arkadaşlarım dinliyorsanız
öğrencilerinize böyle anlatmayın bunu
map bunu istemiyor artık sadece mantıken
öğrenciler arkadaşlarıyla dünyanın bir
yerinde konuştuklarında oradaki saatin
kaç olabileceğini mantıken bulabilsin n
istiyor Çünkü günlük hayatta
kullanabileceği bilgileri istiyor
İstanbul'da saat 12 2 iken kır Doğu
boylamında hakkaride Saat kaçtır bunu
bilmesine gerek yok öğrenci Evet tarih
değiştirme çizgisini de öğrendik Evet bu
konuyu da bitirdik Bir sonraki derste
projeksiyonları ve ölçekleri öğreneceğiz
Orada da güzel mantıklar var Onları da
kaçırmayın hemen bu bu dersten sonra
soru çözümü var bu derse de Paraf attık
soru çözümünde görüşmek üzere